but yeah I'm doing this [ __ ] movie
with Snoop and basically you know Snoop
is a big peewee football guy he's been
coaching for [ __ ] years so he made
essentially he's making like Bad News
Bears but with peewee football yeah so
he's the coach of like the underdog team
the movie's called underdogs and I'm the
coach of the like the bougie team I'm
like the villain yeah so fire yeah it's
fun and Snoop is like like uh I've like
done films with some people now and like
acted with some people now and some of
them have ego and some of them don't and
he is by far the most encouraging person
I've ever been on really that's that
like literally goes hey man this is your
scene like just go for it rip oh that
Line's [ __ ] really funny keep that
one in really and the the lines are
making fun of his character that's
sometimes you have an ego even about
your character yeah and he's just like
nah just go for it I I thought it was so
cool man really cool
yeah he's just the [ __ ] man that
versus with DMX I was so blown away by
Snoop he's so sharp at this age he
smokes weed all the time apparently but
still just a shot like there's a part
with their freestyle and DMX is just
going for like I mean uh assuming just
going for like five straight minutes
just offer everything yeah and I was
like yo this guy's a [ __ ] smart guy
and hearing he's cool and humble is
that's just the best oh yeah yeah did he
smoke weed on set I didn't see it but
there's kids so I Think It's Tricky yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah did he smell like
weed no wow no no no no but like an
interesting figure tall yeah skinny real
skinny yeah like very unique looking
yeah it's one of those things where like
obviously we've seen him for so many
years so there's that as well but like
the way he looks is particular you don't
mistake him for anyone yeah
also you know what I'm saying you're
also interesting how he went from
gangster rapper to this guy who's like
funny and like a caricature but then
aware of why he's funny yeah and now
he's almost like somebody would look at
who's just funny and you can rap yeah
like that's crazy that's how he's had
three decades of longevity yeah yeah so
it was cool man it was it was a and it
was fun like they even let me kind of
just do my thing and yeah that's the
most fun thing for me is if I'm not in
my head you know I was like super in my
head when I did a thing with Eddie
obviously with my [ __ ] hero and then
with all these other actors they're so
[ __ ] amazing I'm like am I gonna [ __ ]
it up or whatever yeah and the more
experience I kind of have I think this
is just natural in life like the more
you know about a topic when you're
talking about it the more confidence you
can have right so like the more I know
how to behave in these scenes and the
more I know what to do the more
confidence I have and um and it was fun
and I think that that is the thing I
learned earlier is like be funny early
and then they'll give you a longer leash
right right like prove that you're funny
and then they you being funny helps
their job yeah right right they look
good if like you're watching up the
script in real exactly and the writers
are never upset like I had a writer tell
me once this guy Doug I had a couple
lines I was like is it cool with you if
I just like spit some things he goes
bruh I'm gonna get the credit
it says written by me not you yeah so
I'm like oh [ __ ] that that works out for
both of us yeah yeah you get the credit
it helps you and I get to say the thing
that like maybe feels more naturally
natural to me but it's cool and uh we're
gonna make a movie guys I just want to
let you guys know that I've been telling
you guys yeah like there are things that
I've noticed about filmmaking that uh I
want to learn more about it and I want
to learn more about like story and all
these things I'm not going to disrespect
the craft but um
we can we can absolutely do it Are You
Gonna Act in the movie yeah oh yeah I
want to act on it I guess it'll be it'll
be it'll be absolutely yeah okay it'll
be absolutely incredible yeah because of
that
no I wanna uh yeah yeah I would like to
act out absolutely but uh most
importantly want to be involved in like
the creation of the story
no no one plays themselves can I play
Alex yeah
nice this movie's awesome yeah this is
the best movie ever Yeah by you yes
absolutely yeah you can play Mark done
no but it can't be about us they have
the same age you have to have a great
but yeah so it was actually a cool
experience which is uh
which is nice because you know me it's
hard to get me to [ __ ] go yeah yeah
you hate it you really hate it sometimes
yeah I don't like the boredom but I'm
learning how to deal with the boredom uh
I I this is the this sounds like such
[ __ ] uh what is it called first world
problems where the [ __ ] but like um
we're so lucky where we get to do things
that we love right we and and we get to
focus on those every single day and it's
like a real blessing that we get to like
work every day and are like into the
things we're doing it's cool
you go on a movie and you just sit
around all [ __ ] day
I mean you're just there all [ __ ] day
doing absolutely nothing and I feel
guilty doing work because I'm like well
do I know my lines enough am I ready
could I find a way to make this scene
funnier could I find a way you know like
so I feel guilty not working on the
scene but I'm not going to read the
lines for myself for eight hours in a
row before I go do I try to go on a tick
tock for six hours you should do that
yeah yeah that works you should do this
that's awesome that's actually super fun
I like this experience yeah yeah I just
scroll for six hours so but yeah so it's
like how do I use that time and I think
it's basically just being prepared
accepting that you're gonna have some
fun things happen in the moment and then
once you feel like you're there work on
some other [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah work on
some other [ __ ] [ __ ] so that's that's
been that's been cool yeah it's dope
yeah I'm I'm yeah we got to get Snoop on
the Pod once the movie comes out hell
yeah 100 guys that'd be legendary yes
would you would you smoke with Snoop I
it is I don't smoke I don't like it but
there's one person I could not say no to
smoking with and that is Joe Rogan oh
sorry
also Joe Rogan but but yo snoo man come
on bro it's Snoop yeah I would get high
with Snoopy yeah right crazy yeah come
on dude yeah let's do it that would be
scary though because I've heard stories
of his week his life yeah I got very
small tokes